Mr.
Prime Minister,
it didn't take you long to get,
uh.
1 bad assessment.
You are 7 weeks old,
give up the echo-fiteau plan,
sacrifice the future to the present,
my two-to-two the question
environmental and the question,
uh. Agricultural.
Tragic ball at Matignon de mort,
agriculture and health.
You are not 1 visionary,
Mr. Prime Minister,
you are 1 demagogue.
You have this week,
for the 70th anniversary of the call of Pierre Bay,
successful tour de force
to be called the S law.
R. U.
And its objective of social diversity in housing
already heavily weakened.
You who speak
of civic rearmament,
you will give 1 bonus to the scoundrel
to those
who have not complied with the law for years.
You have this year
increased the price of electricity by almost 10%.
while the Energy Regulation Commission
by suggesting the decline,
thus increasing the bills
ofcent-cinquante-trois euros
on average for 1 couple living in 50m2
you don't want
that work pays for a living,
but that it pays for your
your invoices.
You have
this week again put the teachers in the street
and succeeded in getting the resignation
the rector of the of Paris,
to bury with him 1 reform aimed at
introduce more social diversity in the classroom
preparatory.
You are not the first middle class minister,
you are the one of the classes to do.
You have this week
succeeded in further penalizing workers,
uh. Lord.
By the deletion
the specific solidarity allowance,
many people in
highly vulnerable situations will be victims
of your budget choices,
while you carry the weight
in the department.
You have just arrived,
Mr. Prime Minister,
it is already time to leave
because we know
that you will not clean what you have soiled
and you won't fix what you broke.
But as you attach to the truth,
I want to recognize
on 1 point that you have kept your word.
All bodies that have not met
these last 12 months will be abolished,
you said.
And you played the talking act by
definitely
your left.